the investigation of ten pipe bombs sent
to critics of President Trump is now
focusing on Florida law enforcement
turned their attention to US postal
center in opa-locka that's near Miami
yesterday sources tell CBS News
investigators believe that some of the
packages may have been processed right
there officials have seized mail bombs
addressed to eight people across the
country including former President
Barack Obama former Vice President Joe
Biden and former Democratic presidential
candidate Hillary Clinton Manuel
Bojorquez is at the US postal facility
in opa-locka with what we're learning
about the possible origins of some of
those packages man well good morning
good morning a law enforcement source
tells CBS News quote a lot of arrows in
this investigation point to Florida in
fact last night Homeland Security
Secretary Kirsten Neilson confirmed some
of those packages were sent from this
state likely investigators say what
could have happened as they were dropped
off at a mail facility in South Florida
and eventually made their way here to
this facility behind me in Alba laka for
sorting now this facility is massive it
handles the mail that is incoming and
outgoing from across South Florida
hundreds of thousands of packages are
reportedly sorted here every day
investigators say the devices were all
mailed in manila packages similar in
appearance with a return address in
Florida to Democratic congresswoman
debbie Wasserman Schultz her name and
Florida were misspelled on the label
which experts say could have been
intentional to try to throw off
investigators those investigators are
also looking at surveillance video from
postal facilities the miami-dade Police
Department at this point is assisting
the FBI in this investigation
bianna oh so many do investigators at
this point think the bomb maker is from
South Florida not necessarily this could
have been a person who very easily made
their way to South Florida to put those
devices in the mail clearly there are
major interstates here major airports
and you have to remember that in
previous similar cases like the
Unabomber suspects are known to go out
of their way hundreds of miles to put
those devices in the mail it looks like
at this point there's zero
in on that location man well thank you
so much